and I think the key thing to home in on
is that disagreement doesn't have to be
disagreeable it may and it if it does it
may get into the zone of hurting
people's feelings but as I've mentioned
to more than one student in my teaching
career I don't mean this to be offensive
but I care a lot less about your
feelings than I do about your Pursuit Of
[Music]
Truth
hello everyone watching and
listening today I have the pleasure of
speaking with the sitting president of a
think tank conservative think tank the
Heritage Foundation Dr Kevin
Roberts we discussed the operations and
practical utility of think tanks the
state of progressivism in the academic
environment how mult multiple
generations of students have now been
rendered incapable of facing adversity
while claiming to fight it and why
intellectual combat is not something to
shut down but to Champion Against All
Odds so you know I was much older than I
should have been as an educated person
to understand what a think tank was and
how they operated and you know I'm
probably not as clear about all the
details still as I might be I don't know
anything about their history or I don't
know who set up the first one I don't
really know exactly who draws upon them
and why and what effect they have on
public policy at the local and state and
National level and so maybe we could
start by just having you give everyone
watching and listening a a good
description of what a think tank is and
to put them in context before we start
talking about your Think Tank and
specifically great question at at its
base any Think Tank whether it's on the
political left or the political right or
in the center starts with research it it
it may focus on a certain set of public
policy issues the purpose of that
research is a little bit different maybe
even a lot different in some cases than
the research that you might do as a
professor that I was doing as a history
professor and that is the purpose of the
research at a think tank is to affect
the outcome of public policy some think
tanks will only focus on the Arch other
think tanks as I'm we'll no doubt
discuss will use that research and then
hire people to go Advocate that is to
say that they're lobbyists to directly
influence the outcome of public policy
whether that's at the federal level in
the United States obviously with
Congress and the executive branch at the
state level or even at the local level
so they are to sum up quasi academic
institutions in fact many people will
leave Academia strictly defined you the
university to do work at a think tank
although there are many people who are
professors full-time at universities who
do project or contract based work for
think tanks I I understand as a
concluding point to to this definition
of think tanks broadly that the United
States has the most robust vibrant
system of think tanks across the
political spectrum of any place in the
world so about how many high-end think
tanks are operating in the US and are
they predominantly a conservative
Enterprise or a liberal or a progressive
Enterprise is it distributed across the
political
Spectrum it's it's fairly distributed
across the political Spectrum although
in the last generation or so say the
last 25 or 30 years the the proportion
of high-end think tanks of which there
are maybe a dozen maybe 15 in the
country the proportion of them who are
on the political right has increased and
and I think that's a result of the
conservative movement maturing if you
will many if not most of these think
tanks are based in Washington DC
although a couple of them are based
elsewhere in New York there are some
think tanks on the right including one
that I used to to lead that's based in
Texas there there's a growing number of
state-based groups that are affecting
not just their own State policy but also
federal policy so well it also may be
that that there's been a need for
conservative think tanks to emerge
because as is well known on statistical
grounds rather than merely being a
consequence of a conspiracy theory there
are virtually no conservatives in
Universities at The Faculty level and
certainly vanishingly few in the social
sciences and the humanities which is
where most of the research that pertains
to policy would otherwise be conducted
and so you could imagine that the
establishment of private and Enterprises
that are devoted towards research on the
conservative side might do something to
redress that imbalance and I understand
that Heritage Foundation of course
certainly plays that role do you think
that's also contributing factor to the
emergence of the conservative think
tanks in the
US it's it's huge in in fact not that
that my story of of how I became
president of the Heritage Foundation is
the most important or the most
instructive but that example that you
just mentioned of Professor
who are politically conservative in the
social sciences and Humanities being in
small number is something I lived out
you know in fact when I was in graduate
school at the University of Texas not
known for its political conservatism out
of a few hundred graduate students in
history I was the only conservative I
was aware of of those of us who were
teaching assistant 60 70 of us I
absolutely was the only one and so it
was no surprise to me when I had my
tenear track job at a Southwestern
public University that I was the only
conservative in fact as would no doubt
surprise you in the entire College of
Liberal Arts and Sciences there was only
one other right of Center Professor I
was aware of out of a couple hundred
faculty and so the relationship between
that fact that reality and the emergence
of a growing number of conservative
think tanks is very direct because many
of us have said forget the the
mistreatment which is not an
overstatement of conservatives in the
social sciences and Humanities and
public policy we're just going to go
directly or work directly for these
public policy organizations especially
those that want to work on higher
education policy or education policy r
large so I'm going to ask you a bit of a
Meandering question
um it's partly a description of how I
became aware of political corruption in
the social sciences
Enterprise so I train trained as a
clinical psychologist and a clinical
researcher and that's actually a very
different discipline than social
psychology and so social psychology is
at the intersection let's say of
sociology and and psychology um it has
to do it focuses on the effect of group
affiliation let's say on psychological
processes and it's a radically leftist
dis subdiscipline and I would say it's
quite corrupt and one of the ways I
discovered that corruption was by
beginning to investigate the technical
structure of the belief system that
makes up progressivism or left-wing
thinking especially leftwing
authoritarianism and as I delved into
that I learned much to my shock I would
say that there was an insistence among
social psychologists and then everyone
that was influenced by them that there
was no such thing is left-wing
authoritarianism that authoritarianism
in and of itself was only a conservative
phenomena and a right-wing phenomena
phenomenon and um that and I I really
couldn't understand that at all you know
because the evidence that there's
left-wing authoritarianism to call it
compelling is to say almost nothing I
mean you could make a very strong case
although it's a vicious battle that
left-wing authoritarianism has been
responsible for more misery and death in
the 20th Century than right-wing
authoritarianism it's a you know it's a
rough contest but when you have someone
like Mao on your side on the left it's
difficult to defeat him on the brutality
scale and you know social psychologists
didn't begin to admit that there might
be such a thing as leftwing
authoritarianism literally till
2016 we did some of the first research
in that area so one of the things I'm
wondering about is what if you can pull
yourself out of your conservative
proclivity let's say and your role at
least in part as a lobbyist what did you
see when you were operating within the
university
system that indicated the danger of an
academic system dominated not only by
liberal individualists let's say but
even more particularly by so-called
progressivists what did you see that
doing to dis say you could speak more
particularly to history for example sure
well I'll I'll start with with an
anecdote from the time when I was a
young tenure track but still untenured
Professor which which and you understand
the the vulnerability I had especially
given how outspoken I was in this
episode but then I will also speak to
something that has happened in my field
which is early American history but in
particular African-American history and
and for people who are listening to us
I'm decidedly a middle-aged bald white
guy which means that I could no longer
according to the the powers that be in
Academia be a specialist or an expert in
African-American history but let me
start with the aforementioned anecdote
this was uh about roughly 20 years ago I
forget the exact year but President
Reagan had had recently passed away and
my colleagues in the history Department
decided now remember as I've mentioned a
few minutes ago they're they're all big
Libs they decided they were going to
host a symposium about Reagan's Legacy
and they were going to spend some money
to Market this around our campus and you
know Prudence probably suggested that I
just keep my mouth shut but I just
thought while I don't think anyone's
perfect Reagan was a great but not a
perfect president there simply was not
going to be a fair objective assessment
of his legacy of as president of the
United States and so I I talked to my
other conservative friend the other
conservative in the College of liberal
arts who was an economist and I said
well let's go join this panel of four
historians and let's offer a a balanced
opinion those four other faculty members
had no reason to do anything other than
proceed with their conversation but
because of the uh the scheduled
appearance of the two of us as
conservatives they canceled it and they
canel it because as you know well from
your own experience
they they can't stand the disagreement
and and and frankly although they
wouldn't admit it I think they were
fearful of the facts that we would bring
to the table and and so that if that
anecdote is helpful it's helpful in this
way that is just emblematic of
everything that's wrong with University
but in my field what has happened is
that someone say today in their early
20s who wants to go to graduate school
in history and wants to study americ
American Indian history African-American
history the history of a particular
culture if they themselves are not
members of that particular culture
they're not even going to be allowed to
study it and so I was beginning to see
the evidence of that when when I was
still in Academia and I saw that in
terms of research grants I saw it in
terms of class assignments that was
given by my history department and and
Jordan This was mild I mean it was a
kind of thing that was just a mere
annoyance but it's now become systematic
such that if my own children came to me
and said dad you know we want to go
study such and such field in history or
political science or
anthropology barring just a handful of
schools in North America I I would have
to discourage them from doing that right
right right okay so I want to delve into
that a little bit too you know so I've
spent a lot of time thinking about
thinking about its nature and about its
relationship to free speech and its
relationship to conflict and
disagreement so let me lay out some
propositions and you tell me what you
you think about them okay so the first
proposition has to do with why you
should think at all now people will
avoid thinking because it is difficult
right it's it's it's technically complex
and demanding and so there's reason
right there not to engage in it it's
emotionally challenging right because if
you already abide by a certain principle
and then you go at it even in your own
imagination hammer and tongs and you
start to shake the foundation then well
that exposes you to cognitive entropy
and that produces anxiety and that's
very well documented in the Neuroscience
literature so there's every reason not
to question your own presuppositions on
the emotional side so it's difficult and
it's emotionally demanding and then on
the social side if you're thinking with
someone which basically means that
you're exchanging verbal ideas then
there's the possibility of eliciting
disagreement and the emotional
unpleasantness and possible conflict
that goes along with that right as well
as the fact that if you expose yourself
to someone who thinks differently than
you they can challenge your
presuppositions and make you anxious and
leave you bereft of hope so those are
all the reasons you shouldn't think and
then you might say well given all those
reasons to not think why should you
think and the answer to that the best
answer to that I've ever seen is
implicit in the ideas of Alfred North
Whitehead Whitehead said and I think
this is true from a biological and
evolutionary perspective that we learned
to
think so that we could allow our
inappropriate thoughts or impractical
thoughts to die instead of us
so you could think of a thought not so
much as a description of the world but
as a virtual a fragmented virtual Avatar
you send it out in an exploratory foray
to see if it can withstand any trials
and if it can't then you dispense with
it now and there's some cost to that the
emotional cost and so forth but the
advantage is you don't act out the
stupid ideas and
die and so the I'm I'm laying this out
for the listeners and Watchers so that
they can understand why CU you might
they might be thinking well do you
really have to engage in contentious
disagreement at the academic level if
you're a thinker why can't everyone just
get along and the answer is well some
ideas are stupid and impractical and
it's better to kill those suckers before
they make themselves manifest in the
world and in order to do that you have
to be disagreeable and offensive now no
more than necessary you know I've really
seen a difference there for example
between the North Americans and the the
Brits because the Brits at their best
their education system teaches them to
engage in like blood sport cognitive
combat and to do that in a very
civilized manner right so that they keep
the argument within the domain of
rationality and abstraction it doesn't
spill over into interpersonal conflict
and part of what universities were
supposed to do was train people to do
that right to think critically to think
in a manner that risks disrupting
themselves and their interpersonal
relationships without that spilling over
into actual conflict right and to
replace conflict with with thought now
we seem to be dispensing with that and
interestingly enough so there's a bunch
of things I want you to comment on my
experience in Academia and in the
broader political world has been I have
never talked to someone who is
conservative once and tried to set them
up with a potential combatant and had
them refuse to participate or refuse to
associate with that person and that has
happened to me well trying to set up
conversations dozens of times with
people on the left I started I saw that
starting at about 200 10 at the
University of Toronto that's it just
sort of crept into the discourse so well
so maybe I could get you to comment on
the necessity of combating thought but
then also I'd be interested in your
ideas about why this proclivity to
cancel seems to be so manifest on the
left you'd expect there to be right-wing
you know tightly bound right-wing
thinkers who were also inclined to
cancel and shun but that hasn't been how
it's been manifesting itself at least
for the last 15 years well the
intellectual combat is essential at at
the University level in fact the the the
very atmology of the word university it
talks about or or or is based on the
unification of thought it doesn't mean
the unanimity of thought it means that
there has been a process in place by the
way I agree with you exemplified by
British institutions and and British
Scholars on the left and right toward
whatever capital T truth is and in
American institutions especially since
the 1940s and accelerating in the 70s
that there's basically the absence of
that in fact the opposite of that so
that if you go and you say that I I want
to do intellectual combat you know
somehow you're committing some grave sin
inside the American Academy but it's
essential because that's where we refine
our own positions and I I'll just use an
example of of what think tanks do just
to go back to to that question the think
tank at its at its height I would argue
is one where of course it's going to
have a particular set of positions that
it's taking publicly but the process of
arriving at those positions inter
internally is one where there is as I
like to call it here at the Heritage
Foundation creative conflict and and am
I nearly two years here in almost every
meeting that I have with our policy
people I asked them well what would the
competing the alternative position be
and what case would we make for that
what evidence would we Marshall for that
because first of all we we need to
question our assumptions but secondly
given that the reason we do research at
Heritage is in fact to effect change in
public policy we ought to be better
prepared for the attacks that will come
but the to your second question very
related which is why it is that in in on
the political left there is this absence
of of uh of that kind of conflict I
think it's because ultimately the most
radical part of leftism is one that
undermines truth very actively they've
they've sort of lost as as Yates would
say in his famous poem they they've lost
the center they there's nothing cohering
their their mode of thought and if you
look at what's going on in the political
right something that you've been talking
about and researching more in recent
years there's a very healthy sometimes
kind of fractus debate that's going on
about particular policies about the
relationship between the individual and
the state those can be a little
frustrating sometimes in terms of
political outcomes but on the
intellectual level they are important
and they speak to the vitality the
intellectual Vitality of the political
right right
now starting a business can be tough
especially knowing how to run your
online storefront thanks to Shopify it's
easier than ever Shopify is the global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of your business from the
launch your online shop stage all the
way to the did we just hit a million
orders stage Shopify is there to help
you grow our marketing team uses Shopify
every day to sell our merchandise and we
love how easy it is to add more items
ship products and track conversions
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout up to 36% better
compared to other leading Commerce
platforms no matter how big you want to
grow Shopify gives you everything you
need to take control and take your
business to the next level sign up for a
$1 per month trial period at shopify.com
jbp go to shopify.com jbp now to grow
your business no matter what stage
you're at that's shopify.com
[Music]
jbp so we did some research in 2016
looking at predictors of politically
correct authoritarianism first of all we
did a factor analytic study that showed
that there was clearly a set of ideas
that were associated with one another
that you could identify as political
correct authoritarianism so it wasn't
just some right-wing delusion that that
coherent system of ideas existed and
then we looked and we did that by asking
a very large number of participants a
very large number of political questions
and then subjecting them to statistical
analysis so so that we could see which
opinions clumped together and how and so
there was a liberal contingent of ideas
and a conservative contingent and a
authoritarian left-wing contingent and
so then we looked at what predicted that
and the best predictor was low verbal
intelligence and I think the reason for
that was that the ba the radical
leftists basically offer a
unidimensional solution to a very
complex problem which is that all human
motivation can be uh reduced to power
which is technically Incorrect and
Preposterous and also an extremely
harmful uh what would you call it a
harmful um insistence but it's very easy
to understand and it does provide for
Universal explanatory power and then but
we also found that the personality trait
agreeableness was also a predictor and
agreeableness is associated with
compassion and the thing is you know if
you engage in the blood sport of
critical thinking you do risk hurting
other people's feelings right at least
in the moment now there might be
long-term advantage to that for both
players as there often is when you
settle a fractious issue say between
wife and husband or between family
members there's some combat that's
required to set things straight but then
you get an you get an interlude of
Peace afterward it might also be that
the the radical leftists are also
temperamentally predisposed to avoid
conflict because as they do say
themselves they prioritize compassion
above all in fact they make it a
universal virtue let's say and they
don't understand the necessity of having
to at
least however irregularly tolerate
periods of emotional discomfort to set
things straight so you know I've been
trying to puzzle out I mean liberals
they don't like borders because they're
high in openness they're creative and
they're low in orderliness so they don't
necessarily find satisfaction in keeping
things in their proper place so that's
part of the reason they have a hard time
drawing borders and distinctions you
know so it's why the moderate leftists I
think have a hard time contending with
the radicals but then there's also this
proclivity to prioritize emotional
Comfort over everything else even in the
moment and that isn't commensurate with
healthy debate of the discriminatory
kind that has to occur if you're going
to refine your ideas you know and then
that does expose people in the way that
you already said you know if you
formulate policy and you don't hash hack
the hell out of it in intramural debate
within your own institution and you
launch those ideas out there in the
world they're going to get torn into
shreds you bloody well better be Your
Own Worst Enemy when you're thinking so
that you're well protected against what
the actual World social and natural is
going to throw at you another reason to
think well it it it is and and two two
things come to mind at least initially
the first is I think as I listened to
the last part of what you said in in
reference to public policy I think one
of the frustrations that Americans
presumably Canadians and and and Brits
and many people around the world have
with politics is the absence of what
they perceive to be a real debate right
and and this this is true on the
political right there's a frustration
among Grassroots activists who are
conservatives in the United States about
the absence of a real debate whether it
be about specific policy issues or even
about the sort of social economic
cultural Di di agnosis of the malaise
that has beset the Western World people
especially younger voters who have a
certain bias increasingly towards
center-right politics are looking for
those men or women who are candidates
for elective office who are at least
asking the right questions even if they
may themselves decide that they disagree
with that person's answer they just want
the questions asked and and as we then
focus on public policy I don't know how
public policy organizations can be
prepared for the media that their
Scholars do the testimonies say for
example that our Scholars at Heritage do
without having a just a vibrant internal
process of disagreement and I think the
key thing to home in on is that
disagreement doesn't have to be
disagreeable it may and it if it does it
may get into the zone of hurting
people's feelings but as I've mentioned
to more than one student in my teaching
career I don't mean this to be offensive
but I care a lot less about your
feelings than I do about your Pursuit Of
Truth your your the intellectual rigor
that goes into not just the the
particular field that we might be
teaching in your case the behavioral
sciences and my case history but even
more importantly your relationship as a
human person as a citizen of the poity
in which you live to everyone else to
the state itself and and ultimately to
sum up here I think one of the problems
with radical leftism is that this
radical emphasis on the individual
creates a radical emphasis on the
individual's
feelings okay so so let's delve into
that a little bit too
because the thing is that radical
emphasis on the
individual is predicated on a very
strange acceptance of what constitutes
the individual because what you see with
the henis
radicals is their insistence that their
immediate emotional or motivational whim
defines their
individuality right I want what I want
right now and no one has any right to
stand in my way now the problem with
that is that it's a pretty low order
conception of what it means to be an
individual it's also extremely immature
and I can speak about that technically
so the more immature you are the more or
you are ruled by motivations that want
to attain gratification right now
regardless of medium to long-term cost
and so actually what happens is that you
as you mature and you learn to quote
delay gratification which is an
oversimplification you learn to
subordinate the demands of immediate
motivational and emotional states to
long-term social harmony and your own
long-term well-being and that requires a
sacrifice of that immediate
gratification so the one of the weird
things about the left is that the
individual who they make sacran is an
individual defined by his or her
subjugation to their own honic
motivations that's a pretty low order
conceptualization of the self right and
so I don't I don't see it as a true
individuality as all as well and then on
the feeling
front see one of the things you're
trying to do with students at a
university is to make their ident their
conception of themselves as an
individual less dependent on their
unconscious
aums so you know take take I saw this
very frequently I I'll take an example
that might not be obvious given the
tenor of our
conversation I took a very biological
approach to psychology in my lectures
and it wasn't that uncommon for me to
have a very fundamentalist Christian
Student student who had been raised in a
household that insisted that the theory
of evolution was incorrect and that the
world was you know relatively new 6,000
years or 4,000 years old and their my
insistence on an evolutionary approach
especially combined with the fact that I
also gave Credence to let's say the
judeo-christian tradition was very hard
on them and it was partly because their
faith and their vision of themselves and
their vision of the future was
predicated on the assumption that you
couldn't have that Faith or that Vision
Without
accepting a non-evolutionary account of
creation and that was where their
feelings came into it right because by
upsetting that
presupposition they be that risk
exposing those students they risk
exposing themselves to anxiety and
hopelessness so it's not feelings per se
that at stake it's the automatic and
unquestioned
assumption that the Integrity of your
psychological that your psychological
Integrity rests necessarily on the
acceptance of certain axioms now when
you go to university those axioms are
supposed to be
questioned now and what that implies is
that you help the student replace their
self-conceptualization they stop seeing
themselves as the static adherent of a
set of dogmatic beliefs and they start
to see themselves as someone whose
stability is partly predicated on their
ability to dynamically transform and to
learn and to engage so they become more
of a dancer than a than a rock let's say
and a good University can guide them
through that process so they don't
identify with those dogmatic ideas to
the to the same degree they can detach
themselves from the ideas and that also
can help them allow the necessary death
of their stupid ideas to occur without
undue psychological suffering right
right and that's the debates you have in
seminars and so forth are practice for
that right under relatively civilized
conditions where the stakes are
comparatively low and now we've insisted
that everybody become a you know a
delicate Snowflake and that you're never
to step on anyone's toes and all we're
doing as Greg lukinov has demonstrated
quite clearly on the clinical front all
we're doing is removing the possibility
from our students of exposing themselves
to the sort of challenges that would
actually make them strong we actually
making making them weaker more hopeless
and more anxious by by protecting them
in that manner and and we've been doing
that long enough that those hypothetical
students although you've you've had real
students who who fit that profile as I
have have become members of Congress
they've become members of United States
Senate and so they lead with their
feelings they lead journalists sure they
lead with with the belief that you can't
even ask them a fair but difficult
question and that of course is is
exacerbating the problems that we see in
the political sphere but I I just want
to respond to your excellent example of
of you leading with Biology in your
lectures and encountering a student who
who believed that the theory of
evolution was incorrect as you may
remember I I've LED I founded and then
LED another College of faith founded a k
through2 school and there because it was
a classical great book school and we had
our particular Faith dogmas as a Roman
Catholic school we made sure that our
students were in classes that were
questioning those assumptions even about
our faith before they went into
apologetics so even for someone who is a
a very devout member of a particular
denominational faith it doesn't mean
that we should be hostile to the hard
questions about what we believe in fact
speaking as someone of Faith who
believes in the mysteries of my faith we
we we ought to really encourage that and
so that's a way of saying that even for
those of us who are politically
conservative you know perhaps
religiously conservative as well that we
ought not develop the same hostility to
this creative conflict these questions
about our the assumptions of our belief
that the left of course personifies
every day well I think you could make a
very strong case that your genuine faith
is actually directly proportionate to
the degree that you're willing to allow
that Faith to undergo the most stringent
of challenges I mean if you have to hide
away and never be you know called to
account for what you presume there's no
faith there there's just there's just a
blind abandonment of reason and the
necessity of hiding from reality in
order to keep those axioms intact right
I think this is partly why for example
there's a powerful bibl bibical
injunction in the New Testament to do
what you can to even love your enemies
which is a hell of a thing to ask you
know but if you understand that one of
the advantages to adversarial enmity is
the refining of your own beliefs then
you can also understand how it might be
possible if you could manage it to
welcome the most Dreadful of challenges
in the hope that see I thought about
this in terms of you know you remember
in the in the Genesis story when Adam
and Eve are barred from Paradise God
places cherubim at the entry to to
paradise and they wield swords that are
on fire that turn Every Which Way and
I've been thinking about that image it's
very dramatic and Powerful image and a
strange one and it also begs the
question of why God would do such a
thing and I think the answer is this is
that if the goal is re-entry into
something approximating a paradisal
state then obviously everything that
isn't fit to be there has to be cut
away but that also indicates another
issue which is that if you confront an
adversarial enemy and in their
adversarial argumentation they can
demonstrate to you where you're weak and
unworthy even though that'll be painful
because you have to let that go and that
might be a lot of you the net
consequence could be that what grows
as a replacement in consequence is much
better for you and for everyone else and
it does seem to me that that's an
evitable it it follows the same logic in
some sense as the necessity for critical
thinking itself you know you have to
think critically so you can put your
ideas to the test and this is also why
free speech is so necessary in the same
manner you're not good enough thinker to
think up all the objections to your
idiocy by yourself you have to allow
other people to
call you out but the net benefit of that
in principle and this is what we hoped
in universities obviously is that if you
exposed yourself enough to the
eradication of your stupidity then what
would be left would be something much
more solid and flexible and dynamic and
adapted and sophisticated and beneficial
and productive all of that and I think
all of that's solid in terms of
psychological Doctrine so that's partly
why it's so appalling to see the
universities take this
false compassionate turn and Hyper
protect their students instead of you
know trying them by fire so to
speak it's solid as as psychological
Doctrine it's also solid in terms of of
Doctrine in in Civil Society right
because what happens is that especially
with with the Advent and popularity of
social media going back to your your
principle about thinking at its base
eliminating those really kind of dumb
thoughts that we have inappropriate
things that should never be put into
practice people aren't thinking but
they're exercising their free speech in
a rather messy way on social media and
then so ironically to kind of come full
circle in our conversation their
feelings are hurt because in the absence
of their thinking which would eradicate
some of their dumbest thoughts they are
posting ideas some of them are elected
officials at very high offices maybe
even the president of the United States
or the vice president of the United
States
and their feelings get hurt because of
all of the the the the push back that's
created as a result of how dumb their
comments are all of this goes back to
what's lacking in our secondary schools
our elementary schools our universities
which is creating not just the habit of
thought but creating the physical space
I mean literally the classroom where
this is practiced and where our our
feelings become harder to hurt because
we've had a lot more experience
mentioning some kind of dumb thoughts
and people explaining why they are well
we're also in the community there we're
also in a community there this is one of
the things that's quite different from
the online world you know like and and
I'll ask you how your think tank is
constructed because of this so if you're
in a seminar let's
say there's the possibility of
developing interpersonal relationships
so that would be a means of
communication and potential friendship
that would iterate across time and that
broader container that's community-based
can help butress you against the
fractiousness of momentary disagreement
right you can think this used to happen
politically too when people actually
lived in Washington instead of just
sojourning there as say as Congressman
you know 40% of congressmen sleep in
their offices now so it used to be that
you could have a scrap with the guy
across the aisle and then go for a beer
with him afterwards or meet him on the
golf course or you know go play baseball
go to a baseball game with with him and
his kids and a lot of that's disappeared
from Washington the problem partly the
problem with the online discourse is
there's no community of reciprocal
interaction that binds people together
at the same time the expression of their
random opinions divides them and so I
wanted to ask you about that on the
think tank front how is the Heritage
Foundation actually set up how is it
constituted how often do you people meet
how do you establish the preconditions
for fractious thought while maintaining
the social the underlying social
community and keeping people United in
Vision let's say as they move
forward well our first rule to your
point about being in person and and
being living in community is that any
conversation that may have a difference
of opinion which at least in our Think
Tank would be many has to be in person
that we're not going to have that
conversation via email we're not going
to have that convers ation by phone
we're also not going to have that
conversation via video conference and
because we the purpose of our research
isn't just to write a white paper but
for that white paper's ideas the ideas
of the author to actually take shape and
ultimately become law we have to do that
work in person it's it's very difficult
to advocate for these ideas without
being in the office of a member of the
house or a member of the Senate so
that's how we live out that first rule
but the second rule is that as long as
the debate doesn't become
personal everything is fair game the
assumptions the principles the
applications of you know what we would
call the the permanent things Timeless
conservative principles to our
particular circumstances and and I will
say in the last two years at the
Heritage Foundation in part if not in
large part because of getting past some
of the co nonsense we're really living
that out in a vibrant way in fact we
often have friends you know whether
they're Financial supporters or just
supporters of of Another Kind who will
visit and and they find it remarkable at
the intensity of the debates that we
have here while also recognizing the
third thing which is that for us culture
is everything by that we mean internal
culture that is to say that when you
walk in the doors here we want this to
be the most cheerful place in Washington
DC I understand that's a low bar but for
us our cheerfulness our Hospitality goes
hand in hand
very fittingly as you know with our
willingness to be engaged in a very
intense debate with our friends and
colleagues you've heard us talk about
how important it can be to have a VPN to
protect your online privacy but choosing
a VPN you trust is equally as important
now we like to do our research on our
sponsors and only recommend Brands to
our listeners that we believe in we can
say with full confidence that expressvpn
is the best VPN on the market here's why
expressvpn doesn't log your AC AC it
online lots of cheap or free vpns make
money by selling your data to
advertisers but expressvpn doesn't do
this they even developed a technology
trusted server that makes their VPN
servers incapable of storing data at all
expressvpn now uses lightwe a new VPN
protocol they engineered to make user
speeds faster than ever other vpns can
sometimes slow your connection but
expressvpn is always blazing fast and
lets you stream videos in HD quality
with zero buffering the last thing that
really sets expr VPN apart is how easy
it is to use you don't need any
technical skills to get set up just fire
up the app and tap one button to connect
that's it even your grandparents could
do it and it's not just me saying this
CNET Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn the
number one VPN in the world so protect
yourself with the VPN that we use and
Trust visit expressvpn.com Jordan that's
expressvpn.com Jordan for three extra
months free expressvpn.com /
Jordan so you know I just did a seminar
on Exodus in Miami we it was 162 hour
sessions they've been released on
YouTube and we did one 8 day session and
then we broke for 6 months and did
another 8-day session and one of the
things we did we brought together nine
people and we kind of knew each other
but not that well and um there was a
wide range of opinions on the panel from
moderate left to pretty socially
conservative no real Progressive types
but certainly people on the moderate
left and um we found we we were really
attempted to be hospitable to all of our
guests so in addition to having the
seminar lay itself out for two hours
each evening I hosted people continually
at an Airbnb that I rented there and we
barbecued together and I rented people
some jet skis and we had some fun and
like each night was a party and at the
same time that that was happening I was
also while we were walking through
Exodus and through other elements of the
Old Testament and I was struck by the
immense emphasis in those texts on the
absolute sacred nature of hospitality
right as a
duty and I came to understand thinking
that through but also watching what was
happening with this seminar was that if
you're hospit to people and this is
partly speaks to the necessity of an
actual localized Community then they
begin to trust each other at a
fundamental
level there's a core of consensus and
Trust there Mutual regard for Mutual
well-being that then
enables experimentation to take place at
the cognitive fringes in an atmosphere
of trust right and humor and so I've
really been struck in Washington
Washington you know I've been talking to
people there people involved with the
Presidential Prayer Breakfast and one of
the things they've said repeatedly is
that the Civil Society in Washington has
broken down in the last four decades
partly because of virtualized
communication so people don't have to be
present partly because under n Gingrich
there was incentives for congressmen to
spend more time in their district and
less time in Washington which might have
had some benefits but also helped under
the Washington Society because of the
difficulty in having congressmen bring
their entire families to Washington for
what can be a relatively brief career
right they have to disrupt the career of
their spouse for example and so one of
the thing and so many of them as I said
don't even have apartments in Washington
now they don't make friendships or
establish social relationships even with
the people in their own party much less
talking across the aisle to Republicans
for example if they're Democrats so that
so okay so now you said at the Heritage
Foundation that you have fostered an
atmosphere you know you said it with a
bit with a bit of irony um because it's
a low Bar in Washington but that it's a
very cheerful Enterprise and so what do
you think you've done right to Foster
that atmosphere the atmosphere that
enables robust debate to occur without
it degenerating into ill will well the
most important thing is that we our our
mission which is focused on
revitalizing self-governance in this
country and across the world is very
unifying and motivating and so the
people who want to work at Heritage are
people who are are animated by that and
in our selection process of how we hire
someone whether at the junior level or
the senior level is not just about
philosophical or political alignment but
it's as much about cultural alignment
that is to say a lot of the interview
process is focused on how this potential
colleague is going to to fit into our
process of creative conflict and and
that creative conflict as we've
discussed being something that never
swerves into the personal and is so
focused on on the ideas and and our love
for the ideas but I also want to mention
that that's very much related to your
excellent and accurate point about the
the sort of demise of Washington Society
I mean I've heard from so many long-term
members of the Senate so many long-term
members of the house and these are
stalwart conservatives who don't wake up
each day looking to compromise with the
left they say that they and their
spouses have seen a a huge deterioration
in even members of the Republican Party
spending time together now as you said
there are certain benefits to that you
know being home in your District or your
state but there are also benefits to the
people who do the good work in
Washington DC and there are some to
having community and and I'll just give
you an example example that is uh that's
self-critical when I first got here
about 2 years ago I was always talking
about DC being a terrible place to live
and no doubt there are parts of DC that
are but at the same time sometimes in
the same paragraph I was encouraging
relatively young conservatives to join
our presidential transition project
which we call Project 2025 and one of
them mustered the courage after one of
these talks to come up and say Kevin you
know those two things don't go hand
inand if you want people to leave their
communities their Hometown you know
their their lives if they as they have
established them wherever home is and
come to DC and in your words tithe two
or four or eight years to the next
conservative Administration maybe
Heritage needs to spend some time
helping to revitalize that Society
helping to revitalize that community and
that was a really good constructive
criticism that we've taken to heart
because of the culture that we have here
at Heritage yeah well well it it points
to a broader problem too I would say on
the conservative side practically and
philosophically I mean there are plenty
of reasons for conservatives for example
to engage in the kind of dialogue that
we've been engaging in in this
conversation for example to uh level
substantive criticisms at the
universities as institutions and of
course we've taken the odd Sid shot at
the Washington establishment let's say
in the political process per se and
that's very problem atic on the
conservative side because the
progressive Mantra is that all
institutions are so corrupt they should
be demolished and replaced and to the
degree that conservatives engage in
incautious Social critique it seems to
me that we play they play we play to the
degree that I'm a conservative into the
hands of those very progressives right
and there BS another question too is but
you know you're it's a matter of of
drawing lines always a matter of drawing
lines where and and how to include and
exclude now you want to produce a
culture that's hospitable and unified
but that's also capable of fractious
debate and you said that precludes for
example hiring people who are of the
progressive left how that how in the
world do you think you manage to
determine when it is that someone has
ideas that are sufficiently different
and novel so that they can add to the
utility of the fraces debate but not so
disruptive and novel that they violate
the tenants of the community and that
would allow if you answer that that
would also allow you to expound on the
central ideals of the Heritage
Foundation you said revitalizing
self-governance is part of the Heritage
Mission and I assume that the people you
hire have to accept the validity of the
central message at least right there's
got to be some core Axiom that unites
everyone but how do you differentiate
well how do you solve that conundrum and
what do you think what is the
Central Access around which the entire
Heritage Foundation rotates let's say
what are you guys aiming at and why yeah
great question especially as it relates
to hiring people which we've been doing
a lot of over the last last couple years
because of growth the the focus of of
Heritage in terms of policy is that we
need a much more limited federal
government and and not just because
limited government is an end unto itself
but because it is a symptom of
flourishing by individuals who are
living in community who are also of
course enjoying greater self-governance
but in terms of specific policy that
we're looking for there's the typical
list that people would expect that if
you're going to have a more limited
government you're going to have a fairer
and Taxation system that's probably
lower states are probably going to have
more author to make decisions that are
closer to the people they're governing
there's a certain belief on the foreign
policy side that America should be
strong although in the Heritage View
that strength needs to be more
restrained and less expensive and less
adventuresome than the the neocons of of
the last generation we're arguing for
and we also believe to speak about not
surprisingly to you the policy I care
most deeply about in education that
every dollar that Americans spend on
government funded schools should follow
every child to the school of his or her
parents Choice that's just a a brief
smattering of the specific policy issues
but they all if you think about it speak
to the preeminence of the individual in
his or her community working at the
local level and eventually the state
level having great authority over the
federal government and so ultimately to
to be succinct about this the Heritage
Foundation exists to devolve power from
Washington back to the States and
ultimately back to the people themselves
now if you pause and think about that
there's room for a lot of differences of
opinion at least at the very least
differences in priority right and so to
your question about people coming in uh
job applicants coming in there's going
to be some difference of opinion but
what we're looking for is the the
absence of a disagreement on some of the
core principles and now I'll speak to
I'll speak to them uh probably the best
the the the best summary of these in
addition to to Heritage products would
be the historian Russell Kirk's great
essay on the 10 principles of
conservatism which emphasize things like
continuity prudence and change Community
if if if someone's wanting to work at
the Heritage Foundation and they don't
understand or appreciate those or they
don't have a concern about what I think
is the greatest problem in in America
today which is fatherlessness the
deterior ation of the family and that if
we if we fail to address those on the
social and cultural and maybe even
policy fronts that we're everything else
we're working on is almost mooded then
there's going to be a philosophical
misalignment but there's also still even
within that uh that set of of positions
that we have opportunity for great
differences we have some economists here
who are going to say that as it relates
to the so-called family policy public
policy Arena that the only thing that we
need to do is to make sure that we're
ending the disincentives to marriage and
family formation and American tax law
there are others of us who might more uh
commonly be called social conservatives
who say there may be a role for the
state whether it's the federal
government or a state government as the
nation of Hungary and nation of Israel
have done to actually proactively Aid
marriage and family formation for for
the sake of saving Society all of that
to say because we're a think tank in the
interviews with policy people or
perspective policy people we have these
conversations and it has become in the
last several years in conservative
public policy pretty easy to far it out
when someone's not completely on the
reservation if you will and and perhaps
the most common conundrum that we have
just to give a a precise example would
be on the nature of the free market for
so many years I mean my entire
upbringing uh to be conservative was to
believe that the free market was some
sort of alter that in fact free market
belief was tantamount to being
conservative and while the free market
is a good free market is a symptom of a
healthy Society Healthy Families good
public policy it isn't the end unto
itself and so I mention that example
because it's the most common
conversation that we have internally
when we're interviewing po Cal policy uh
colleagues but also when we're having
conversations internally about how to
help the American political right
navigate this reality that so many
leaders of the so-called free market
aren't even in the free market
themselves the most leaders of Fortune
500 companies actually hate
conservatives and hate conservatism the
Heritage Foundation is I would like to
think leading the way and beginning to
resolve that conflict okay well I have a
bunch of questions about that so
the first comment in question I suppose
is one on the Strategic front so I think
the conservative mve movement has
weakened its argument for the
decentralization of Power by aligning
that argument too closely with
libertarian neocon and free market
principles because it often devolves
into a like a a a proclamation that a
government that's too large is too
dangerous which I do believe but that's
not the crucial issue as far as I'm
concerned that if the government was
smaller the tax burden would be less if
the tax burden would be less that would
be better because people should be
economically free and they should be
economically free because well the free
because the society functions better
when the free market is as untraveled as
possible and so it's kind of a in some
ways it's an an a Rand philosophy of you
know rugged individualism conjoined with
libertarian admiration for the free
market
now there are some problems with that
one you pointed to and we'll get back to
that later I think when we discuss
neoconservatism one is that the free
market itself is probably not the only
basis for an equitable and just and
moral polity it's not the thing that's
at the bottom and I think that's where
the libertarian types have it wrong and
I think there are are good reasons for
that but more importantly the there's a
better reason to discuss the necessity
of devolving power down the hierarchy to
lower levels the first thing I would say
is it's not
power when we shouldn't use that
language because that's the language the
leftists use it's meaning and
responsibility and those things are
aligned and so what happens and I've
really found this idea striking a chord
with audiences that I've talked around
the world is that if you deprive people
of local
responsibility you deprive them of all
the meaning in their life because the
meaning in their life is actually a
consequence of taking responsibility for
themselves taking responsibility for
their marriage for their family for
their local community for their business
enterprises for their town for their
state for their country in that order
right and then maybe to God and
responsibility obtains at every one of
those levels that's the sub subsidiarity
idea of course but the purpose for that
is that if you devolve that
responsibility down the hierarchy you
re-instill the meaning in people's lives
the meaning that sustains them through
catastrophe and so because you got to
ask you know well why why should the
typical young person listen to a
conservative who says well you should
take more local responsibility because
it sounds like a lot of work a lot of
Duty and something that's not
particularly hedonically gratifying but
if the answer is well if you forgo that
responsibility you have nothing to
sustain you when you suffer and you
forego the possibility of formulating
the extremely tight and reciprocal
social interactions that buttress you
through life and you deprive your life
of intrinsic meaning then that seems
like a very bad idea for you and I found
is very striking everywhere I've gone to
talk if I make that connection between
responsibility and meaning the audiences
fall completely silent it always happens
because no one see we haven't had a good
discussion about the relationship
between meaning and responsibility in in
the West for like 60 years right since
the mid-60s it's been a long time it's
been a very long time people assume that
there's no meaning outside of a kind of
a narrow Hedonism or that there's no
meaning at all and that and that's a
very dismal that's a very dismal set of
propositions and it is a weak place in
the Progressive Enterprise because
sustaining meaning is found in
responsibility and really in
self-sacrifice or at least the sacrifice
of the narrow self now this this
insistence that you your Enterprise has
on this subsidiary vision is that
grounded at least in part in Catholic
Social Doctrine because that principle
of subsid it is okay you want can you
elaborate on that a bit sure and the
Heritage foundation's non-
sectarian but we're animated by the
judeo-christian intellectual tradition
and as as we discussed earlier in
reference to education I'm Roman
Catholic but the the the effect of
subsidiarity on heritage's mission of
course long predates me we've been
around 50 years and it's just because
it's it's a vital part of our Western
intellectual tradition as as you
explained so well and I think it's it's
an excellent way given the conversations
on the political right right now to talk
about the issues we're discussing here
about meaning and responsibility it's
related very much to something that has
become more common parlance in
conservative circles which is to say
that the reason we want a more limited
government isn't because of some uh
doctrin belief that the free market is
always better than government that's not
the case it's because there is an
inherent dignity that comes from work or
are put more broadly there's a dignity
that comes from responsibility and
therefore we have greater meaning it's
no surprise to me that you've gotten
that wonderful response in all of those
talks when you when you emphasize those
points
because people not only know that that's
true just intuitively right naturally
the second thing to come back to my my
constructive criticism of of free
marketis conservatives myself included
years ago have done a very poor job of
taking advantage of that great
vulnerability of the political left that
you identified which is this very issue
because our response to that for 20 or
25 years was well the free market will
take care of it pull yourself up from
your bootstraps read read on Rand it's
all going to be okay just work a little
bit harder well in reality that isn't
true in the first place but this is
really key it's especially not been true
since the mid 1960s with the illn named
war on poverty because what that has
done is actually a eradicate for two
generations of Americans the meaning and
responsibility that every human person
should have therefore in order for just
to kind of swerve into the sidewalk
level as I like to say if conservatives
are going to succeed in safety net
reform and so-called welfare reform we
first have to get better at talking
about the limitations of the free market
and the necessity of conservative
principles conservative political Dogma
to be associated with our long tradition
of living in community which actually
has a longer history in conservatism
than even free market
principles we talk about pre-born a lot
on our shows here at the daily wire we
believe in their mission and we know you
do too who wouldn't want to help mothers
and their children in crisis pre-born is
reaching into the hearts of women by
allowing them to hear the hearts of
their babies and introducing them to
their precious lives it's a Divine
connection that doubles as a baby B
chance at life everyday pre-born network
of clinics rescues 200 babies lives but
it doesn't stop there your gift of $28
for a free ultrasound goes directly to
Women in Need and pre-born doesn't take
any of that money they independently
fundrais for their team to continue to
make a difference they offer mothers
maternity clothes doctor's visits and
the help they need all gifts are tax
deductible and will go directly towards
saving babies lives to donate just dial
pound 250 and say the key word baby
that's pound 250 baby or donate securely
at preborn
docomo that's pre-born
docomo well that also points to a place
where social conservatism and the more
free market end of conservatism the
libertarian end could be unified right
so okay so let's let's concentrate on
responsibility for a moment so I'm going
to speak about that psychologically so
someone young might be thinking well why
should I bear up under the load of
additional responsibility and I would
say
well if you responsibility is going to
be a challenge it means you have to
determine that you are going to lift
something that you haven't yet lifted
and then you might say well why should I
do that and the answer is something like
so you get stronger and better and so if
you decide to take responsibility for
yourself then you put yourself through
the paces that will dis you enough so
that all your idiocy and bad habits all
the ones that interfere with your
ability to take care of yourself
disappear now often students do that to
some degree when they go off to
University because they have to learn
how to live independently right which is
a big part of what university does and
that burns off the remaining childhood
idsy that they've carried with them
right that dependence on their parents
and maybe the dependence over dependence
on their initial peer group so they have
to mature and the whole the utility of
taking on responsibility is that you
confront yourself with necessity in a
manner that forces beneficial change you
know and you might say well why does it
have to be forced and the answer is well
you know we don't know how much
situational privation and necessity has
to be there to motivate people to
develop now you could take on just
exactly the right amount of
responsibility you know so it would feel
like the challenge was optimized right
but that also that optimized challenge
is also what puts you in the zone of
proximal development and forces you to
expand your horizons and so you adopt
responsibility you can care for yourself
then you can care for other people
better but that also does genuinely make
you a better person in that your domain
of competent action expands in precise
proportion to the amount of
responsibility that you've been willing
to undertake voluntarily right and it's
not surprising that that's associated
with meaning so the conservatives can
sell the leftists can sell rights rights
rights which is what they've been doing
forever and the hedonic self
gratification that goes along with that
but the right can sell the deep and
abiding meaning that comes with the
hoisting of voluntary responsibility and
that is that's not a free market
argument right it is not free market is
a consequence of that exactly the free
market isn't going to work and this is
where the social conservatives have an
edge too and I think this is becoming
increasingly obvious in the absence of
that underlying ethos of responsibility
responsible conduct you can't have a
free market because people have to be
able to trust each other before the free
market can even get going and you can't
trust your responsible people that's the
precise rub and and and I will tell you
that any any uh leader in a public
policy organization has certain things
that he or she does every day every
single day either directly or indirectly
I'm dealing with that tension on the
political right because part of what
what heritage tries to do beyond the the
research and advocacy that we do is is
also play at this plane where you and I
are having this conversation on the the
intellectual level and and when we do
that what we're arguing for is is I like
to say an unhyphenated conservatism
we're we're we're all of those things
but when you're all of those things
you're not trying to be you know
something to to everybody we're talking
to our audience on the political right
it means that you're also going to be
aware of the limitations of some of the
things that are Goods like the free
market the free market is good but there
are many higher goods and and as we've
talked about chronologically speaking
which is which is what I try to do
almost every day in reminding more free
market oriented friends on the right is
you have to have that healthy Society
you have to have as I often like to put
it healthy families you you have to have
this this moral system in place to even
give birth to the free market it was the
the monks of salaka in the 1200s who
first came up with this concept and even
Adam Smith himself I think would be very
very comfortable in this this exchange
that you and I are having about the lack
of privacy of the free market as it
relates to human Goods yeah well that's
a matter of putting everything in its
proper place right that's and and it is
an open question how far down the
hierarchy of axiomatic Primacy the free
market rests but yeah and the more
libertarian types they're going to say
it's right at the bottom and Ein Rand is
a good exampler of that right for her
the free market is the god out of which
all other Goods emerge but I think the
Adam Smith conceptualization the classic
British liberal conceptualization for
that matter is much more accurate which
is that once you have a society that's
essentially predicated on the judeo
Christian axioms one of those being
responsible self-sacrifice and the trust
that emerges from that then you can
instantiate a free market and it can
serve a it can serve a governing
function but it can't exist see I think
the same thing is actually true of
science this is something I want to talk
to Richard Dawkins about because I don't
think the scientific Enterprise itself
the scientific Enterprises predicated on
the idea that the cosmic order is good
that we can investigate it that we can
understand it and that if we do that
that will be good those are all axioms
of faith in my estimation and they're
also specifically judeo-christian axioms
there's a bunch of axioms of faith that
are embedded in the judeo-christian
tradition that are also presuppositions
of the free market like fairness in
weights and measure and and honesty in
mutual exchange right because like the
free marketers have a hard time dealing
with a simple question like if I can
screw you over and make money doing it
why shouldn't I that's it's an IR Rand
principle right self-interest is the
most important thing and and the other
thing just to introduce this to this
wonderful exchange that is so true about
the free market in the 2020s is that
what what most Americans think of when
they think of the free market right now
rest it's it's it it almost requires
collusion with what heritage would call
big government right and so what what I
try to do all of us at Heritage try to
do when we're talking about the best
aspects of the free market is to place
the emphasis not on those companies that
are they're actually seeking regulatory
favoritism actively by agencies in DC
don't put the emphasis on them instead
put the emphasis on small businesses on
entrepreneurs in America who actually
are the ones creating the jobs they're
much more in line with this proper
understanding of where the free market
Falls in that list of of of axioms for
the conservative Dogma yeah
well one of the places that the left and
the right the more socially conservative
classical subsidiarity right could be
aligned and I see this emerging in
people like Russell Brand and Joe Rogan
right is that there's every reason to be
Su skeptical of towers of Babel rather
corporate or govern or government yeah
well the thing is is that once something
gets so large that it can capture the
environment in which it's supposed to
thrive then it presents a danger and it
doesn't matter whether it's a
corporation or a government and that
means that all of us left and right
alike like the the lefties are always
saying oh my God big corporations and
you know looking at the behavior of the
pharmaceutical companies for example
over the last 20 years you can have some
sympathy for their perspective and then
the Libertarians say oh my God big
government and neither of them seem to
notice that the unifying horror there is
Big right it's out of control big and
the danger of regulatory capture and you
know one of the things we're trying to
puzzle through I started this
organization I'm involved in the origin
of this organization called The Alliance
for responsible citizenship and we're
trying to work through these issues of
subsidiarity but also expressing great
concern about corporate gigantism and
fascist collusion at the highest levels
of the what of the hierarchical
Enterprise right and the true fascism I
would say and
so how have you at the Heritage
Foundation grappled with this issue of
the danger of regulatory capture like
what what policies do you think should
be in put in place I mean like in on on
the YouTube front for example I mean
it's one Corporation now that controls
the primary communication Network for 7
billion people and in the main they've
done a pretty damn good job but
YouTube's got a bit heavy-handed on the
censorship front as has Facebook you
know colluding with the Biden
Administration as has come out in recent
weeks how do you guys grapple with the
problem of emergent gigantism say within
a free market framework how do you
conceptualize the solutions to that
problem well three things come to mind
the the first is and and I don't mean
this to be just sort of academic Think
Tank speak it's it's really important on
the on the political right for us to be
doing this as a first step because of
this 30 40 year long held position that
the free market equates to conservatism
and that is to remind people that
regulatory capture is a result of soall
quote unquote free market leaders going
to government and asking for favorable
treatment the second thing which is more
substantial in terms of of what we do on
a day-to-day basis is through our
project 2025 roughly speaking it's a a
presidential transition project where
we're coming up with the policies
including deregulatory policies for the
next conservative Administration but
it's also one and this is vital that as
important as the policy is we're
recruiting 20,000 people to go into the
next conservative Administration and if
that happens then you're going to see
across the board from the Department of
energy to the Department of Education
which we've written the plan to
completely destroy we we need that
eliminated by the end of this decade to
completely starting from scratch with
the FBI what this public policy
organization the Heritage Foundation
does isn't just talk about those things
and we don't just come up with the plans
we're actually recruiting the men and
women who will put that in place
hopefully as soon as 2025 but the third
sort of kill shot if you will the that
that one bullet that will be really
helpful to ending regulatory capture is
schedule F reform it's the civil service
reform that will give the next president
of the United States power to fire the
bureaucrats who are part of the problem
but if that's all you do and you don't
take the first step which is to explain
on quote unquote our side you know the
sort of business free market side that
we have to call out those businesses
that are asking for this kind of of
treatment then we're not going to solve
the problem okay so I have two questions
that arise from that um one is on the
presidential candidate front VI gramas
Swami has made comments about uh the
destructuring of the so-called
managerial deep state that are akin to
the proposals that seem akin to the
proposals that you're putting forward
part of Trump's attractiveness was his
promise to do that so let's leave that
aside for a moment I want to return to
Rand and Rand for a minute I've just
been rereading out the shrug which I do
uh oddly enough about every 15 years
years and I figured out one of the core
problems with her Doctrine it might be
the core problem so she assumes that
self-interest is the appropriate
governing principle but she never really
defines what constitutes self-interest
and that's a big problem so because you
can have narrowly hedonic
self-interest and Rand actually wanders
into that territory because her
protagonists RoR and dagy tager and so
forth do have and express quite
continually their right to do whatever
the hell they want whenever the hell
they want to and that they should be
guided by no other principle in some
sense than the gratification of their
own desires but that's exactly what the
hedonists on the left say and so this
begs the question of what constitutes
the individual whose self-interest is at
stake and where ran makes a mistake is
she doesn't understand that there's a
set of constraints that operate on what
constitutes individual self-interest
interest so you're you don't exist just
right now you exist out say decades into
the future and in an attenuated form in
your descendants and what that implies
is that every action you undertake right
now has to be bound by the necessity of
not betraying that sequence of future
selves and I don't think there's any
difference in a game theory from a game
theory perspective of the collective
that is you across time and other people
so I think that enlightened
self-interest and social interest are
exactly the same thing and I don't think
that Rand understood that right is that
she seems to believe that there's this
internal self which is the part that's
self-interested that's almost like the
internal self the radical leftists
insist upon being able to establish such
things as gender
self-identification right that's 100%
autonomous and unmowed that can
operate itself as a autonomous governing
principle it's almost like a deity and
it's a it's the same it's the
conservative version of the same mistake
that the radicals on the Progressive
side are making I think that's exactly
right in fact you talked about you
yourself rereading Atlas Shrug I do that
with about the same frequency and the
last time I did three or four or five
years ago it's because I had a a junior
colleague at the policy organization I
was leading prior to being at Heritage
who was a capital O objectivist and and
I thought well let me let me reread Rand
and see if I'm missing anything and be a
good colleague a good Mentor and I
realized this actually sort of come full
circle rereading Atlas Shrug four or
five years ago ironically is what made
me realize my own deficiencies in
thought about the free market and a
couple of other shilas of of the right
which is to say that so many very
thoughtful men and women who are
devotees of Rand make the mistake that
she's making and they haven't thought
through the consequences of that as it
relates for example to regulatory
capture and so the exciting thing this
is all very troubling on kind of on an
intellectual level but the exciting
thing is that we're finally having these
conversations on the political right and
the exciting thing for us at Heritage
often referred to as a legacy
organization is that
I wouldn't say we're necessarily driving
those conversations but we're very
active participants in them and that is
to the extent that we've got credibility
with people on the center right in
America it's it is L we're lending that
credibility to that conversation which
must happen in order to achieve the
public policy ideas that we've had for a
few
decades well the way that
Rand Maneuvers around the complexity of
those questions say with regards to
regulatory capture is that she
attributes to her
protagonists a kind of a vague nobility
of character right so that it's
distasteful for roor and tager for
example to engage in any plaintive
negotiations with government agencies
right it's beneath them to ask for
favors from government but she never
establishes why it's beneath them right
it's vaguely associated in principle
with their self interest and their
implicit heroism but it's very difficult
to derive that heroism from that narrow
self-interest and I think the reason
it's difficult to do that is because it
doesn't derive from that narrow
self-interest it derives from the
necessity of a higher order
self-interest that has the community as
an intrinsic part of itself and she's
very weak on that front right because
her characters taggard is a good example
and so is work Works in a very unhappy
marriage and dagy taggard is single
those people aren't Bound by like
they're all Noble individual Heroes who
stand alone they're not well situated in
happy marriages they're not as couples
well situated in functional families and
she's almost rouso she's almost rousan
in that regard she seems to regard any
form of higher order social involvement
as an impediment to the Noel Noble
strivings of the disaggregated
individual and so it's very strange to
see that dovetail with the more radical
ideas of the progressive left that's
definitely a flaw in her thinking right
both both from the perspective of
characterization but also from the
perspective of Ethics it's that narrow
self-interest that's not the that's not
the highest self that's not the true
self it's just the immature and
impulsive self and she tries to make
that Noble and it's not Noble it's just
immature so that's exact I think that's
why her I think that's why her work
never hits it's like Rand is not
dovi right there's a shallowness about
her work that's I like reading it it's
exciting it's adventurous it's a
romantic adventure you know and it's got
a strong hero narrative element but it's
definitely not literature and I think
the reason for that is that her
characterizations are too they're too
simplified
you won't be expecting this reference
I'm sure but I grew up reading Louis
LaMore books you know written in the
20th century but they were 20th century
versions of the of the western dime
novels of the late 1800s GRE read them
as a boy and every time I guess I've
read atas Shug three or four or five
times I don't mean to be too offensive
toward Rand followers but we've
established that feelings are okay to
hurt um the her characters are just as
flat as the great heroes in Louis LaMore
novels who showed up in these Western
towns and they were rugged individuals
right and there as a as a 10 or 11year
old boy those were good things to read
in the same way that there's a certain
value to reading rand's work but it's
not literature it's certainly not dovi
and in the in the Great Book schools
that I've LED Rand had no part of the
curriculum and and I'll just make this
final point if I may on on this thread
the way this plays out in conservative
politics and by that I mean not elected
officials but to some extent the donor
class but these are these are thoughtful
men and women most of whom have made
their their own wealth themselves is
that they think that those characters
from Atlas Shrug are the model but in
reality I mean almost without exception
as I think about these men and women in
their own lives they are living out that
higher order thinking or set of values
far better than Ran's own characters in
other words they themselves these
devotees of Rand personify the
limitations of the book uh it's it can
be hard to explain that to them because
they're they're so committed to this
mode of thought but the the point is the
more of those devotees of Rand who come
to grips with those limitations the
quicker the American political right
will be able to resolve this conundrum
we have about the community and about
the free market yeah well I I think I
think that your characterization of
Ran's books as sophisticated Cowboy
stories is exactly dead on because first
of all she was attracted to that rugged
American individualism not least because
she was an escape from communist hell
and so she had a reason to Hero worship
that that pattern of rugged
individualism and it is associated in a
genuine sense with the with the Great
American Dream which is a real
phenomenon and and something to be
reckoned with but but but the fact that
her characters and and some of her
characters they're almost literal
Cowboys I mean in in in Atlas Shrugged I
can't remember the gentleman's name but
Wyatt that's his name he's even got a
cowboy name Wyatt he runs a sequence of
oil R oil rigs and oil Explorations in
the in the frontier State of California
right and he's definitely a cowboy in
every sense of the word and and so are
the rest of her male characters and so
um
you can also understand that that
admiration for rugged
individualism has a place if the rugged
individuals are already nested inside
like a stable couple and a stable family
and a stable community and so forth if
all those preconditions are met then you
should go out on your individual
Adventure but if none of them are met if
you're that sort of cowboy you're almost
indistinguishable from a
psychopath and so
yeah so that's a big problem it's the
same problem on the free market side
right the free market doesn't work
unless it's embedded in an underlying
ethos and that rugged individualism
doesn't work unless for exactly the same
reasons unless the underlying pre
preconditions of stabilization already
in place and it's very much related to
to the the excellent point you made
about meaning and responsibility right
because part of that responsibility you
know part of of of Freedom properly
understood not in a in a randian way
is the the moral duty that's
conferred that that for those of us who
emphasize the natural law over you know
what the left liks to talk about rights
that moral duty is to the community it's
to the other as much as it is to our
ourselves and those those two things
more often than not can actually not be
intention they can they can be resolved
and exist harmoniously and it's it's in
that Gap just to be kind of simplistic
here where properly ordered government a
properly limited government exists as I
like to tell people the Heritage
Foundation is a conservative not a
Libertarian public policy organization
we see a very proper role for government
and and we look forward to getting it
back into that
box well I would say mature identity is
the balance between the interests of the
individual and the interests of the
extended individual and the collective
that Harmony that Harmony as well is
what people mean when they say sanity
like sanity isn't something you carry
around within you sanity is the
harmonious balance between your
interests and the interests of you in
the longterm and other people it's
actually the manifestation of that
balance you know and I'm going to say
something in favor of ran too because
there are elements of her thought that
are subtle you know so if you say that
the individual has an obligation to the
community then that obligation can be
twisted and bent by people who will use
moral guilt as a cudgel and she does a
nice job of outlining that so she tells
a story for example of a of a factory
that decided to run on the principle of
to each according to his need and from
each according to his ability and she
shows how that and that that was foisted
upon the workers right so the so she
shows how that immediately degenerates
into a competition of
victimization and slavery to that
self-described victimization but she
fails to make a distinction
between me being burdened by force with
the needs of other people and me taking
on the
responsibility as a voluntary choice to
address the needs of other people and so
that would be the difference between
being a slave let's say and having a
family I mean you're both working for in
both situations you're working for
someone else the good of your children
let's say but in the case of a well
constituted family you're doing that
voluntarily and that makes all the
difference it makes all the
physiological difference too because a a
burden undertaken voluntarily is much
less stressful physiologically than the
same burden foisted upon you
involuntarily the data on that are very
clear so she does a nice job of
insisting that whatever responsibility
is undertaken has to be undertaken
voluntarily but that's also the same as
that call to responsibility that we were
discussing earlier she makes a she makes
a a great reminder about that and and I
think again to kind of swerve into what
we do every day or every week at the
Heritage Foundation what we try to do is
acknowledge these tensions in in in our
movement a broad intellectual movement
resolve them in a way that allows people
to have the creative conflict But
ultimately we're not just having those
conversations right we're trying to to
do that to resolve those tensions so
that we can develop popular support for
Public Policy Solutions and and and I
would be remiss if I were not to say
that rather than just being
headquartered and supported here in the
Imperial City of DC we're distinctive if
not unique among public policy
organizations on the right because of
how we're supported which is hundreds of
thousands of people across the country I
say that not at all to make a
fundraising pitch but to explain that we
are as I like to say the everyday
Americans Outpost and so it's I mean
it's highly highly improbable that the
Heritage Foundation would be captured by
these these excesses of the nation's
capital I I I mentioned that in
reference to what you said about Rand
because I think she herself would
appreciate that greatly about how we
work even though we obviously have some
some points of contention with with uh
some of her her key points yeah well
that was actually another thing I was
going to hassle you about maybe I'll do
that to close I
mean there are clearly dangers and and
I'll talk to you about this more I think
on The Daily wire side of this
conversation there are clearly dangers
posed to educational institutions and
other
institutions as a consequence of taking
Federal money government money and I
think that that proclivity for
universities to accept Federal money has
now finally corrupted the scientific
Enterprise itself and because it's it's
gone downhill in quite a catastrophic
manner in the last 10 years um I know
that you've had quals to say the least
about accepting government money but
then the same accusation can be levied
let's say against conservative think
tanks who derive their funding from
gigantic
corporations how do you avoid becoming
an instrument of the same regulatory
capture that you that you protest
against now you just said quite clearly
but I think it's worth reiterating
tell me your funding model and and how
Heritage has protected itself against
capture let's say by the by the Giants
of the corporate world well in in two
ways the first is from the very
beginning Heritage was funded primarily
by small donors uh we have a membership
model and the the average donation given
to Heritage each year is I think
$82 as it was in 2022 we do have some
individuals who make larger
contributions that obviously but we
receive very little I mean a miniscule
amount of corporate money that's always
been the case but it's especially true
over the last few years as Heritage has
sharpened its criticism of regulatory
capture so the that inoculates us uh you
the the membership model that we have
but also the explicit position we have
not to receive corporate money from most
businesses we we receive a little bit of
that but it it's tiny and of course this
is coming from me because when I was at
Wyoming Catholic College we like
Hillsdale and a few other schools
decided that the Department of Education
could keep its money we didn't want to
be captured by their idea so in other
words Heritage has always had this
philosophy but I've underscored it
because of my hostility to that entire
system okay so two two closing questions
the first is how has heritage managed to
fund itself
successfully given its unwillingness to
rely either on government or corporate
money I mean that's a lot of sources of
money go on how have you appealed to
Ordinary People let's say and why has
that worked and and along with that
maybe you could explain to everyone what
they would have to do in order to learn
more about how the Heritage Foundation
operates and to participate in that if
they or at least to learn more if they
if they chose to chose to do so
thanks for asking those questions on on
the first one we have been one of the
few organizations on the right that has
has perfected a particular model of most
importantly the work that we do in DC
it's it's not for our sake it's not for
the sake of the researchers the policy
leads but we really see ourselves as the
advocacy Organization for the everyday
American and when we're able to report
successes in that realm which we've been
able to do a lot and convey that to
individual Americans through direct mail
and all the means that organizations use
to raise money it's been extremely
successful for us over many many years
the second way is or the answer to your
second question is you can go to our
website heritage.org there you will see
most importantly the research we do also
we're very good or we've become better
at giving individual Americans talking
points sort of messaging that's linked
to that that research because we don't
just want them to read the research we
want them to be part of the solution
right we're not just here ourselves to
do the work and then ask them to support
financially what we're doing a vital
part of our business model and it speaks
to the success that we've had is having
individual Americans participate in what
we do such that 10 years ago we founded
we created our own kind of campaign arm
Heritage action for America which gives
our Enterprise the ability to do more
direct lobbying more involvement in
particular campaigns most importantly it
also is is the kind of currency that
elected officials understand which is
the ability to as is the parliament in
our work key vote a particular vote on a
particular piece of legislation yay or
nay and hold those elected officials
accountable they don't like it but
between the research that we have the
hundreds of thousands of supporters we
have and the power of that scorecard
that we keep we've become very
influential in DC as I like to say
we're sort of the the people's Advocate
Behind Enemy Lines okay okay well let
I'll close with a question on that front
then um there are a number of candidates
for president on the Republican side I'm
have no doubt that your organization is
watching that completely surreal race
intensely are there particular
candidates or how are you working with
candidates so that your plan to to
restructure the corporate deep State or
the government deep State dovet tales
with their campaign offers is that
happen happening formally does it happen
informally where do you see an alignment
of interests or a conflict of interests
for that matter great question it
happens both formally and informally
formally because of our tax designation
from the IRS we can't endorse in in a
political race and so we don't but that
doesn't mean that we don't have any
influence over it and the influence that
we try to have over it I think we are is
in ideas and policy and so I mentioned a
couple of times earlier this project
2025 the the policies and and and
Personnel for the next Administration we
have shared those policies with all of
the major conservative aspirants and for
that matter a couple of candidates left
of center including RFK because we are
ultimately nonpartisan in our Tex
designation the informal part of that is
we provide policy briefings to any c
candidate who accepts our invitation for
that we've made that invitation across
the political Spectrum this year I
personally have have done the briefing
for a handful of the I guess more likely
nominees for the Republican nomination
there are a few candidates who are
probably misaligned with Heritage but
those who are highest ranking in the
polls are those we're closest to I will
say this the most important thing for
the Heritage Foundation and our members
as it relates to 2024 is not just that
the most Conservative candidate who can
win the general election becomes our
standard Bearer it's that he or she even
before they take the oath of office on
January 20th 25 is ready to govern in
the most aggressive ambitious audacious
way to destroy the Deep State and
devolve power back to the individual
Americans that's a good place to bring
this to a close so for everyone who's
watching and listening thank you as
always for your time and attention ition
to the Daily wire plus folks for
facilitating these conversations and uh
working so effectively on the production
quality front that's much appreciated
film crew here up in Northern Ontario um
thank you very much for talking to me
today we're going to switch now to the
dailywire plus side I'm going to talk uh
our discussion now will turn to more
autobiographical matters as they usually
do on that side of the platform and so
those of you who are watching and
listening who are interested might give
some consideration to Casting some
attention the daily wire plus way and
other than that thank you very much for
agreeing to talk to me today and uh
thank you to all of you who've been
watching and
[Music]
listening